this is super super interesting
and uh or at least i found it so um
there was a so there's a mayoral race in
new york city we're going to talk on the
bonus show today a little bit about
andrew yang's recent twitter controversy
andrew yang is a candidate in the new
york city mayoral race
recently the new york times editorial
board interviewed
each of the candidates and this is
something that many newspapers do for
presidential races or sometimes senate
or whatever the case may be
with the mayoral race the new york times
interviews the candidates
and they asked the candidates do you
know the median
sales price for a home in brooklyn okay
now i used to live in brooklyn
and at the time when i last lived there
which was i guess
uh when was i last in in that
neighborhood in 2015.
if at the time you had asked me the
median home price i think i would have
said 550
000 based on my understanding of of home
prices
there and two of the candidates uh were
asked about this
sean donovan and raymond maguire and
they were
so far off that it's almost like
do you have any idea what's going on in
the city
sean donovan uh said i don't know for
sure
i would guess around 100 000
which you know when i see that i wonder
if you're that out of touch which with
what's going on with home prices in
brooklyn
what else that's fundamental to the new
york city experience
right now do you have no idea about
and then raymond mcguire who's an
investment banker and former citigroup
executive was very similar he said
it's probably between 80 and 90 000
if not higher now i'm no real estate
expert
you know i i'm involved in a number of
properties in different parts of the
country and i have
you know sort of like a passing
knowledge of the fact that uh in
in east coast cities and and west coast
cities
uh properties are really expensive then
you have sort of secondary cities like
um you know austin and asheville where
property values are
going up but there's still quite a bit
less and then you've got rural you know
i have like a passing sense of it
um how on earth do you get to 80 90 or
thousand 100 median home price in
brooklyn now later one of the candidates
said well i thought you meant
assessed value it still doesn't make any
sense eric
adams who's the brooklyn borough
president said he thought the number was
550
that's the number i would have guessed
back in 2015.
maya wiley former council to bill de
blasio guessed 1.8 million
and andrew yang uh correctly guessed 900
000
it's that that's that's basically right
where we are so
how much do you think this is relevant
in thinking about whether a candidate
can properly manage a city from the
standpoint of
if you so misunderstand something as
fundamental as cost of living
if you underestimate by eight ninths
the cost of a median home in brooklyn
what else are you going to be unable to
sort of empathize with
or understand to me it does seem
like a real problem now uh i this by the
way i don't know how many of you have
seen
bill gates was interviewed by ellen
degeneres a couple of years ago and they
did a sort of similar thing where ellen
asked bill gates you know what do you
think milk costs or whatever and bill
gates had like no idea there was like
some little frozen food thing and bill
gates
thought it cost 20 bucks when it's like
you know if if that thing cost 20 bucks
then
you know it just didn't didn't make any
sense is this relevant
i think it is relevant i kind of did a
self-test where
um i uh wrote down what do i think
gasoline the average home in miami a
gallon of milk
bread and a gallon of eggs cost just to
see if i had
some sense of the the sort of like
national numbers so for gasoline i guess
three dollars and i haven't gotten gas
for a while i've had an electric car
for for some time now and gasoline right
now is at 301
nationally so that's just like a random
guess
i seem sort of clued into that average
house in miami which is a market i sort
of know but not
intimately i guess the median home price
in miami is 350
000 real number is 398 000.
so i'm sort of testing whether if you're
at all
connected to what's going on in the
country
you would be in the ballpark and the
more i was guessing these numbers the
more i think
guessing a hundred thousand for a
brooklyn median home price if you're
running for mayor
is a major red flag average price of a
gallon of milk now i did struggle with
this
because first of all i never buy a
gallon and i know when you buy less
the price per per per ounce goes up i
also admittedly i get hipster milk
i get like the pasture raised organic i
pay like five bucks for a half gallon i
guessed for a gallon of organic milk
it's five dollars it's actually four
um and uh similarly with eggs ever since
reading michael pollan's books about
this
i've decided the extra couple bucks for
pastured eggs and pastured milk i've
just decided it's worth it i don't
consume
so much that it really makes a big
difference so like with eggs i'm getting
those like bright orange yolk eggs or
whatever
it's like six bucks a dozen so i guessed
for like your basic
cage free eggs it's probably something
like three dollars and it turns out it's
266 and then lastly for bread
i struggled with bread because like you
know the difference between a loaf of
processed wonder bread
and artisanal seed bread or whatever
it seems like it's the difference
between a dollar and eight dollars i
don't know
i guess three dollars the official rate
for brett is two dollars and fifty cents
so
like how relevant is this stuff if
you're listening to a candidate
um say that they hear uh
they hear you about the issues in your
city they believe they can fix some
of those issues they want to bring this
and they want to bring that
and then you ask them what do you think
the medium home value is when it's 900
000 and they say
80 grand that seems to me like a
material concern
and i'm curious to hear from you uh
whether you agree
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman we will take a
quick break and we have
so much more upcoming one of our
sponsors today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money
helping the environment but it's
actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off
all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link
is right underneath this video